Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History, the first of this extraordinary epic series of World Cup themed podcasts that we'll be doing. And when I say World Cup, Tom, we are doing a podcast for every country that has qualified for the FIFA Football World Cup are taking place in Qatar, but none of the podcasts are going to be about football or indeed really about sport. They are aspects of a particular country's history, aren't they? With one exception, which is today's podcast, because today we are kicking off with the host nation, aren't we? Yes. So today, uniquely among our 32 episodes uh we're going to give the entire
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。这是我们即将推出的世界杯主题宏大史诗系列播客的第一期。当我提到世界杯时，汤姆，我们正在为每一个获得在卡塔尔举办的国际足联世界杯参赛资格的国家制作一期播客，但这些播客都不是关于足球的，实际上也不是关于体育的。它们探讨的是特定国家的历史，对吧？只有一个例外，那就是今天的播客，因为今天我们要从主办国开始，对吧？是的。所以今天，在我们32集节目中独树一帜，我们将完整讲述
history of a country namely qatar and dominic i guess i mean if you look looking back at previous countries that have hosted it so that would be what russia brazil and france south africa yes so so these are in france yeah these are countries that have a very kind of complex, fascinating history. And they tend to be global players, inevitably, because to host the World Cup, you have to be wealthy. And generally, you have to have a large population. Qatar is, I would say, unique among the countries that has hosted the world cup in that it is incredibly small so it's very very small physically if you imagine that the persian gulf or i guess i should call it the arabian gulf people get very cross depending on where they come from but let's
一个国家的历史，也就是卡塔尔。多米尼克，我想说，如果你回顾一下以前主办过世界杯的国家，那就是俄罗斯、巴西、法国、南非，是的。所以这些在法国，是的，这些国家都有非常复杂、迷人的历史。而且它们往往是全球性的大国，这是不可避免的，因为要举办世界杯，你必须很富有。一般来说，你还必须拥有庞大的人口。卡塔尔，我要说，在主办过世界杯的国家中是独一无二的，因为它的面积小得难以置信。从物理空间来看，它非常非常小。如果你想象波斯湾——或者我想我应该叫它阿拉伯湾，人们会根据他们来自哪里而感到非常生气——但让我们
say they call it the gulf qatar is kind of like if you imagine the gulf as being like a throat qatar is kind of like the epiglottis sticking up. It's a tiny kind of peninsula sticking up. Peninsula, yes. Next to the island of Bahrain. And its population is equivalent to the population of Hull. So it's just over 300,000. There are just under two and a half million expatriates, but there are just over
说他们叫它海湾，卡塔尔有点像，如果你把海湾想象成一个喉咙，卡塔尔就像是向上突出的会厌。它是一个向上突出的微小半岛。半岛，是的。紧邻巴林岛。它的总人口相当于英国赫尔（Hull）市的人口。所以刚刚超过30万人。那里有不到250万外籍劳工，但正式的
300,000 Qataris. And for most of its history, it has existed to be dominated by other great powers. It has not been one of the great centers of the world. It's not been one of the great motors of world history. I think it would be fair to say. That's probably fair, isn't it, Tom? I mean, even a Qatari historian would surely agree with that. Yeah, I think so. And obviously there are very distinctive reasons why Qatar now is such a significant player geopolitically. So it's the world's largest exporter of liquefied natural gas,
卡塔尔公民只有30多万。在其历史的大部分时间里，它的存在就是为了被其他大国统治。它从未成为世界大中心之一，可以说，它从未成为世界历史的伟大发动机之一。这样说应该很公平吧。这可能挺公平的，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，哪怕是一个卡塔尔历史学家肯定也会同意这一点。是的，我也这么觉得。显然，卡塔尔现在之所以成为地缘政治中如此重要的角色，有着非常独特的原因。它是世界上最大的液化天然气出口国，
which at the moment, of course, is absolutely the center of world politics. But it's also, it's not just the fact that it has these large, I mean, the world's largest reserve of liquefied natural gas. It's also what it has done with its money. And it's such a fascinating story, really fascinating story. So very much the focus of this canter through the history of Qatar will be, the focus will be very much the last few decades, because that's really when Qatar has become a geopolitical player. But the backstory is interesting as well, because Qatar is, well, I saw an advert for it.
而目前，这当然绝对处于世界政治的中心。但这也是因为它所拥有的不仅仅是这些庞大的——我是说，世界上最大的液化天然气储量——更是它用这些钱做了什么。这是一个如此引人入胜的故事，真正迷人的故事。因此，我们对卡塔尔历史的快速浏览将主要集中在，重点将放在过去的几十年里，因为正是从那时起，卡塔尔才真正成为了一个地缘政治角色。但背景故事同样有趣，因为卡塔尔是一个——好吧，我看到过它的一个广告，
The tourist industry said it's desert and sea, which is basically what you know. It's sand and salt water. So that's basically why the population traditionally has been quite small, because neither are naturally hospitable. But having said that, the sea for hunter-gatherers has always been a resource because it provides seafood. And in fact, particularly Bahrain, but also Qatar as well, is famous throughout antiquity right the way up into the 20th century for its pearls. So it did have kind of food resources to offer hunter-gatherers as they moved out of Africa, so modern humans spreading eastwards
旅游业说这里是沙漠与海洋，这基本上就是你所了解的。这里只有沙子和盐水。所以这就是为什么传统上人口相当少，因为这两者都不是天然宜居的。话虽如此，对于狩猎采集者来说，海洋一直是一种资源，因为它提供海鲜。事实上，尤其是巴林，还有卡塔尔，从古代一直到20世纪，都以珍珠闻名。因此，当现代人类向东扩散，
across Asia. So populations were there from very very early on um and it qatar was really created rather in the way that um the island of great britain was created by the rise in sea level about 8 000 years ago so the same inundate process of inundation that that drowned the dogger bank it um it it flooded vast uh areas of of land around what becomes the Gulf. And Qatar, it kind of emerges from this Atlantean deluge and it becomes a peninsula and therefore it becomes a refuge for people who are fleeing the inundation.
横跨亚洲时，它确实为离开非洲的狩猎采集者提供了某种食物资源。所以那里很早就有人口了，嗯，卡塔尔的形成其实有点像英国大不列颠岛的形成，大约8000年前海平面的上升，淹没多格尔浅滩的那个浸没过程，它淹没了一大片围绕着未来海湾的土地。而卡塔尔从这场亚特兰蒂斯式的洪水中浮现出来，变成了一个半岛，因此它成了逃避洪水的人们的避难所。
So that is the very, very deep backstory. But basically from that point on, if there is a local superpower, Qatar comes under its influence. So it comes under the influence of the Assyrians, of the Babylonians, of the Persians, and then under the armies of Alexander the Great, it comes under the Seleucids. And one interesting detail that comes from Herodotus, and I'm very happy that our World Cup series, there's a chance for a mention of Herodotus, because he reports an intriguing fact, which is that the Phoenicians who settle what's now Lebanon and who will go on to found Carthage,
所以这就是非常非常深远的背景故事。但基本上从那时起，如果有一个地方超级大国，卡塔尔就会受到它的影响。所以它受到亚述人、巴比伦人、波斯人的影响，然后在亚历山大大帝的军队攻势下，它受塞琉古帝国统治。还有一个有趣的细节来自希罗多德，我很高兴我们的世界杯系列节目有机会提到希罗多德，因为他报道了一个耐人寻味的事实，那就是定居在现今黎巴嫩并进而建立迦太基的腓尼基人——
which will be the subject of a later episode that we do, he says that they came from this region. They came from the region of Qatar and Bahrain. So that's kind of interesting. I can't be right there. Can I? Is that right? I don't know. Apparently, he says that this is what the Phoenicians themselves claimed. So who knows?
迦太基将是我们以后要制作的一集节目的主题——他说他们来自这个地区。他们来自卡塔尔和巴林地区。所以这挺有意思的。那不可能对吧？是这样吗？我不知道。显然，他说这是腓尼基人自己声称的。所以谁知道呢？
I don't know. But Dominic, another of my favourite classical writers is the first person to actually give us the name of Qatar. So can you guess who that is? Can I guess that it's plenty the elder tom plenty the elder yes absolutely it is so very much friend of the show and he's um he's tracking uh all the various peoples who live along the gulf and he he talks of the nachetti the zarazi the bogodi and the cathare oh so the cathare thearis. The Catharis, presumably. What happened to the Bogodi or whatever?
我不知道。但是，多米尼克，我另一位最喜欢的古典作家是第一个真正告诉我们卡塔尔这个名字的人。所以你能猜出那是谁吗？我能猜到是大普林尼吗，汤姆？大普林尼，是的，完全正确。所以这也是节目的老朋友了，他在追踪沿海湾生活的所有各族人民，他提到了纳切蒂人（Nachetti）、扎拉齐人（Zarazi）、博戈迪人（Bogodi）和卡塔里人（Cathare）。哦，卡塔里人（Catharis），大概吧。博戈迪人或其他什么人怎么了？
Who knows? Who knows where they went? And he clearly sees it as a place of wealth and legend. So he's obsessed by pearls. So he's very alert to the fact that pearls can be sourced from here. He describes towns built from square blocks of salt. He describes tribes of Icthaphagi, which are fish eaters. He describes the Gulf as being prey to whirlpools. So it's a place of wealth, of mystique, and of danger. And that's very much the kind of the Roman sense of it. Ptolemy, the great geographer, he produces a map that shows a place called Keturah, which is obviously Qatar as well. They're talking about the same place.
谁知道呢？谁知道他们去哪儿了？他显然将这里视为一个财富与传奇之地。所以他对外貌珍珠非常痴迷。因此，他非常敏锐地意识到珍珠可以从这里采购。他描述了用方块盐建造的城镇；他描述了食鱼部族（Icthaphagi）；他将海湾描述为饱受漩涡侵害的地方。所以这是一个充满财富、神秘感和危险的地方。这很符合罗马人对这里的看法。伟大地理学家托勒密绘制了一张地图，上面显示了一个名为“克图拉”（Keturah）的地方，这显然也是卡塔尔。他们谈论的是同一个地方。
So the Romans are aware of it. Of course, the Romans themselves aren't ruling it. The Parthians rule it. The Sasanians rule it. And then it comes under the rule of the Arabs, the Umayyad dynasty, the first Muslim dynasty. And it becomes a Muslim territory territory a muslim land right but the numbers living there tom must be pretty small i mean it's very nice isn't it it is but it it serves a useful purpose because um you've got in basra which is the port in um the south
所以罗马人是知道它的。当然，罗马人自己并没有统治它。安息人统治它，萨珊王朝统治它。然后它落入了阿拉伯人、倭马亚王朝（第一个穆斯林王朝）的统治之下。它变成了一个穆斯林领土，一片穆斯林土地，对吧？但那里的居民数量一定很少吧，汤姆？我的意思是，这真的很不错，不是吗？确实如此，但它发挥了一个有用的作用，因为——你在巴士拉（Basra）——这是南部的一个港口——
mesopotamia south of iraq which becomes the great port for ships that are servicing Baghdad in the heyday of the Abbasids, the dynasty that succeeded the Umayyads. And they're sailing up the Gulf out into the Indian Ocean, sailing all kinds of, to India, to Ceylon, to Malaysia, across the Indian Ocean and the Pacific. And essentially, Qatar provides a way stop, a readily defensible way stop along the way. So it's the kind of place that you can imagine Sinbad stopping. Oh, yes, absolutely.
美索不达米亚南部，伊拉克南部——在阿拔斯王朝（继承了倭马亚王朝的王朝）的全盛时期，这里成为了为巴格达服务的船只的主要港口。它们驶上海湾，进入印度洋，航行到各种地方，去印度、锡兰、马来西亚，横跨印度洋和太平洋。从本质上讲，卡塔尔沿途提供了一个中转站，一个随时可以防守的中转站。所以这是一个你可以想象辛巴达会停靠的地方。哦，是的，绝对是。
With all the pearls and stuff, I mean, perfect. It's perfect sort of Arabian Nights territory, isn't it? Exactly. So there are pearls. It becomes famous for its horses and for its camels. So it's breeding them. And I think a measure of the way in which, even in the 8th or the 9th centuries, it's taking on a role as a hub, a global hub, is that forts are built then. And they're using a style of masonry that seems to derive from China.
带着所有的珍珠什么的，我的意思是，太完美了。这简直是《一千零一夜》的完美领地，对吧？完全正确。所以那里有珍珠。它以马匹和骆驼而闻名。所以它在繁育这些动物。我想，即使在8世纪或9世纪，它开始扮演枢纽、全球枢纽角色的一个标志是，那时建造了堡垒。它们使用的石工风格似乎源自中国。
So, you know, there's a hint of the Tang dynasty in Qatar, which is very interesting. So it must be part of a trade network that goes all the way. Completely, yes. Via the Silk Roads, I suppose, all the way to China. Yeah, absolutely. All by sea. All by sea. All by sea. Yeah, absolutely. All by sea.
所以，你知道，卡塔尔带有唐朝的印记，这非常有趣。所以它一定是一条通往各处的贸易网络的一部分。完全是，是的。我想是通过丝绸之路，一直延伸到中国。是的，绝对的。全部通过海路。全部通过海路。全部通过海路。是的，绝对的。全部通过海路。
All by sea. Yes, it's all by sea. And so there are also kind of traces of trade with Africa, with Malaysia, with Thailand, gold, silver, spices, all this kind of stuff that basically the Arabs are controlling. So they are the local superpower and they are controlling. They've got access to all the wealth of the Far East. And to the degree that it's reaching Europe, it's having to go through them. And the Europeans resent this, or more particularly the Portuguese come to resent this because of course there are certain Europeans they profit from it, but the Portuguese stuck out facing the Atlantic, very, very peripheral power. And of course, the Portuguese were very much friends of the show because we did four episodes on them. And we talked about how first Henry the Navigator and then King Manuel sent ships going down the side of Africa, down to the Cape of Good Hope, back up as far as India. And the ambition of the Portuguese was firstly to bypass the Muslim control of these trade routes. And secondly, to basically destroy
全部通过海路。是的，全都是海路。因此，这里也有与非洲、马来西亚、泰国贸易的痕迹，黄金、白银、香料，所有这些基本上都是由阿拉伯人控制的。所以他们是当地的超级大国，由他们来控制。他们可以获得远东的所有财富。而就其传到欧洲的程度而言，它必须通过他们。欧洲人对此感到不满，或者更具体地说，葡萄牙人开始对此感到不满，因为当然有些欧洲人从中获利，但葡萄牙人背靠大西洋，是一个非常非常边缘的力量。当然，葡萄牙人非常符合我们节目的朋友，因为我们为他们做了四集节目。我们谈到了航海家亨利，然后是曼努埃尔国王，他们如何派遣船只沿非洲侧翼南下，一直到达好望角，再北上到达印度。葡萄牙人的雄心，首先是绕过穆斯林对这些贸易路线的控制。其次，基本上是摧毁
Islam. I mean, that was their goal. And so the Portuguese make a systematic attempt essentially to take over these trade routes. And so under the command of Albuquerque, this extraordinary figure who becomes the second viceroy of India and who commands the imperial expansion of Portugal, basically across vast sweeps of the world blazed by the Portuguese then gets followed first by the Dutch and then by the English. And sure enough, Qatar then comes under first the Dutch and then the English. So they establish posts there. At the same time, you've got the Ottomans expanding southwards. So it also comes under Ottoman influence. So essentially, it's simultaneously looking at, to the degree that it's looking out to the seas and playing this role of a kind of
伊斯兰教。我的意思是，这就是他们的目标。因此，葡萄牙人系统地试图接管这些贸易路线。在阿尔布克尔克的指挥下——这位非凡的人物成为了印度的第二任总督，指挥了葡萄牙帝国的扩张——基本上横扫了葡萄牙人开辟的世界广大地区，随后先是荷兰人，然后是英国人。果不其然，卡塔尔随后先是落入荷兰人手中，然后是英国人手中。因此他们在那里建立了据点。与此同时，奥斯曼帝国正在向南扩张。因此它也受到了奥斯曼帝国的统治影响。所以从本质上讲，它同时在展望——就它面向海洋并在这些全球贸易路线上扮演中转站角色的程度而言，它处于欧洲的影响之下。但就它处于某种地方霸权的掌控之下的程度而言，它处于奥斯曼帝国的统治影响之下。这是卡塔尔历史上的某种紧张关系，它确实从早期现代贯穿到现代。当地人扮演什么角色呢？1870年，一个财团，一个有着非常具有沙漠风情的名字的阿拉伯部落联盟——巴尼·哈利德（Bani Khalid），他们将奥斯曼人赶出了。是的。这是一个联盟，它包括卡塔尔，但它一直延伸到东阿拉伯的海岸线直到伊拉克南部。因此，他们建立了一个松散的联盟，使奥斯曼人和欧洲人都保持一定距离，尽管不可避免地他们必须与他们进行某种妥协。
way stop on these global trade routes, it's under European influence. But to the degree that it's under the thumb of a kind of local hegemon, it's under Ottoman influence. And this is a kind of tension within Qatari history that really runs right the way through from the early modern period through the modern period. And what role is there for the locals? 1870, a consortium, a kind of confederation of Arab tribes with the very, very dune name of the Bani Khalid. They expel the Ottomans. Yeah. And this is a confederation that it includes Qatar, but it kind of runs up the coast of Eastern Arabia to southern Iraq. And so they establish a kind of loose confederation, keeping both the Ottomans and the Europeans at a kind of remove, although inevitably they have to have some accommodation
作为全球贸易路线上的一个中转站，它受到欧洲的影响。但在某种程度上，它也受到某种地方霸权——也就是奥斯曼帝国——的控制。这是卡塔尔历史上的某种张力，从近代早期一直延续到现代。那么当地人扮演什么角色呢？1870年，一个阿拉伯部落联盟（即拥有非常古老名字的巴尼哈立德部落）驱逐了奥斯曼人。是的。这是一个包含卡塔尔的联盟，它的范围大致沿东阿拉伯半岛海岸一直延伸到伊拉克南部。因此，他们建立了一种松散的联盟，将奥斯曼人和欧洲人都保持在一定距离之外，尽管不可避免地他们必须做出一些妥协
with them. And then in 1783, so that's basically a kind of a century after the Bani Khalid have taken control, there's a further fracturing when the House of Khalifa take over the kingdom of Bahrain. And the House of Khalifa also seize control of Qatar. And the House of Khalifa are in a kind of seesaw contest with a new and aggressive tribal confederation that has emerged in Arabia, who are called the Wahhabis. Ah, now that's going to be a big theme, isn't it? Yes. So the Wahhabis are very, I guess you would call them, they're the kind of the ancestors of what today we might call radical Islam. They are very ascetic. You could almost say puritanical. I mean, that's possibly not the right word, but they are very doctrinaire in their practice of Islam.
然后在1783年，也就是巴尼·哈利德夺取控制权大约一个世纪后，随着哈利法家族（House of Khalifa）接管巴林王国，又发生了进一步的分裂。哈利法家族还夺取了卡塔尔的控制权。哈利法家族与在阿拉伯兴起的一个新的、极具侵略性的部落联盟——被称为瓦哈比派（Wahhabis）——处于一种此消彼长的竞争中。啊，那将是一个大主题，不是吗？是的。所以瓦哈比派非常——我想你可以称他们为我们今天可能称之为激进伊斯兰教的祖先。他们非常苦行。你甚至可以说他们是清教徒式的。我的意思是，这可能不是正确的词，但他们在伊斯兰教的实践中非常教条。
And they're coming from the depths of the desert, whereas the people on the coast, so the Qataris, inevitably are more cosmopolitan. They're more open to foreign influences. They have both the Ottoman and the Arab. So there's actually some really interesting themes there. One of them is the extent to which Qatar is a sort of plaything, I suppose, for foreign powers, or an important, merely, they see it as a node on their trading network and then you've also got kind of local chieftains and clans trying to play off the foreign powers but then you've also got the tension between the desert and the coast i suppose don't
他们来自沙漠深处，而沿海地区的人，也就是卡塔尔人，不可避免地更加国际化。他们对外国影响更开放。他们既有奥斯曼的影响，也有阿拉伯的影响。所以那里实际上有一些非常有趣的主题。其中之一是卡塔尔在多大程度上只是外国列强的一个玩物，或者他们认为它只是其贸易网络上的一个节点；此外还有当地的酋长和氏族试图利用外国列强；但你也面临着沙漠和沿海之间的紧张关系，不是吗？
you yes so these are themes that will that are always there and the wah Wahhabis can draw on such reserves, and they're so kind of aflame with a sense of their own mission, that the Al-Khalifa dynasty have to look for overseas help. And so obviously, they turn to the Ottomans, they also turn to the kind of sub-Ottoman dynasty that's emerged in Egypt. And absolutely, you know this complete awareness from the the the dynasty that rules qatar and bahrain that the only way it can survive is by allying itself with the local great powers and so that's what it does but meanwhile of course moving into the 19th century um this is the period of growing british influence So the English have been keen participants in these trade routes for a long time. But by the 19th century, the East India Company is the dominant power in India.
是的，所以这些主题将永远存在，而瓦哈比派可以调动如此庞大的资源，他们内心燃烧着一种使命感，以至于阿尔-哈利法王朝不得不向海外寻求帮助。因此，很明显，他们转向了奥斯曼帝国，他们也转向了在埃及兴起的次奥斯曼王朝。毫无疑问，统治卡塔尔和巴林的王朝完全意识到，它生存下去的唯一途径就是与当地的大国结盟，这就是它所做的。但与此同时，当然，进入19世纪，这是一个英国影响力不断增长的时期。因此，英国人长期以来一直是这些贸易路线的热心参与者。但到了19世纪，东印度公司成为印度的统治力量。
And seizing control of the shipping lanes that run from Britain to India is obviously of absolutely fundamental importance. And an ability for British shipping to sail undisturbed by pirates is absolutely key. And so in 1820, the East India Company signs a treaty with, or perhaps forces a treaty, on all the various sheikhs along the Gulf um which has as its focus the ending of piracy and also interestingly the slave trade so 1820s we're into the period where uh abolitionism is becoming an absolute motor of british foreign policy this is the period when the royal navy is starting to patrol the atlantic trying to stop the slave trade going from Africa to the Americas.
夺取从英国到印度的航运路线的控制权显然具有绝对根本的重要性。英国航运能够不受海盗干扰地航行是绝对关键的。因此，在1820年，东印度公司与海湾沿岸的各个酋长签署了一项条约，或者说强迫他们签署了一项条约，其重点是结束海盗活动，有趣的是，还有废除奴隶贸易。所以到了1820年代，我们进入了废奴主义成为英国外交政策绝对驱动力的时期。这就是皇家海军开始在大西洋巡逻，试图阻止奴隶贸易从非洲运往美洲的时期。
Tom, this is where you get that phrase, the trucial coast. Yeah. So the coast with which we've signed a series of truces, I suppose, or treaties. Yes, exactly. So I think in our episodes in Portugal, we talked about the Portuguese had a – or was it the Brazilians had a phrase, this is a law to be looked at by the British. Oh, yes, the Brazilians, exactly. The Brazilians.
汤姆，这就是你得到那个词“停战海岸”（Trucial Coast）的地方。是的。所以我们与他们签署了一系列休战协定或条约的海岸线，我想是这样的。是的，完全正确。所以我想我们在葡萄牙的剧集里谈到过，葡萄牙人有一个——或者巴西人有一个短语，这是一条给英国人看的法律。哦，是的，巴西人，完全正确。巴西人。
A law for the British to see. Yes. So I think that that's essentially what these various shakedoms along the Gulf have. Officially, they've signed an anti-slavery law. They probably don't have the slave market directly opposite the British ambassador's residence, but it's still going on. And to be honest, the British are not in a position to enforce it. And it's not really in their interest to do it. So everyone's kind of happy. The British can feel that they've done their bit to stop the slave trade the sheikhs get their
一条给英国人看的法律。是的。所以我想这基本上就是海湾沿岸这些酋长国的情况。官方上，他们签署了反奴隶法。他们可能没有直接在英国大使官邸对面开设奴隶市场，但这仍在继续。老实说，英国人并没有能力执行它。而且这样做也不太符合他们的利益。所以每个人都挺高兴的。英国人可以觉得他们为阻止奴隶贸易尽了自己的一份力，而酋长们得到了与英国的条约，他们得到了保护，他们仍然可以这样做，他们仍然可以从事奴隶贸易。所以这基本上就是19世纪的状况。但具体到1867年的卡塔尔，正如阿尔-哈利法家族从阿拉伯各国的联盟巴尼·哈利德分化出来一样，所以在1867年，卡塔尔提出了独立的主张。或者更具体地说，你看到另一个王朝——阿尔-塔尼家族（Al-Thani），宣布他们脱离阿尔-哈利法家族独立，并在卡塔尔建立了一个次级酋长国。这场战争持续了两年。它由英国人解决，英国人基本上迫使阿尔-哈利法家族接受卡塔尔拥有某种模糊的独立性。他们迫使阿尔-塔尼家族接受阿尔-哈利法家族的一定主权度，从那时起，阿尔-塔尼家族就成了英国的附庸，他们完全依靠英国的支持来维护他们所拥有的独立程度。所以阿尔-塔尼在统治卡塔尔，我没记错的话，阿尔-法尼斯（Al-Farnis）在统治卡塔尔？我没记错的话，阿尔-哈利法在统治巴林？基本的分裂是这样的吗？是的。所以有一个巨大的——我以前从未意识到巴林（一个岛屿）和卡塔尔（一个半岛）之间存在着如此悠久的敌意和竞争历史。好吧，是的，但同时，我的意思是，也有很长的时期。因此在阿尔-哈利法王朝统治下，最初他们统治着卡塔尔。
treaty with Britain they get their protection and they can still do that they can still trade in slaves so that's kind of basically the state of play through the 19th century but specifically what happens in Qatar in 1867 is that just as the al-Khalifa family had branched off from the Bani Khalid, this alliance of various Arab states. So in 1867, you have Qatar staking a claim for independence. Or more specifically, you have another dynasty, the Al-Thani family, declaring that they are independent of the Al-Khalifa dynasty and setting up as a kind of sub-shakedom in Qatar. And the war lasts for two years. It gets settled by the British, who basically force the Al-Khalifa family to accept that Qatar has a kind of shadowy independence. They force the Al-Fahani family to accept a measure of sovereignty
与英国签订条约后，他们获得了英国的保护，并且他们仍然可以这样做，他们仍然可以从事奴隶贸易，所以这基本上就是19世纪以来的现状，但具体到1867年的卡塔尔，就在阿勒哈利法家族从巴尼哈立德这一各个阿拉伯国家的联盟中分支出去之后。因此，在1867年，卡塔尔开始主张独立。或者更具体地说，另一个王朝——阿勒萨尼家族，宣布他们脱离阿勒哈利法王朝独立，并在卡塔尔建立了一个附属酋长国。这场战争持续了两年。最终由英国人进行调停，他们基本上迫使阿勒哈利法家族承认卡塔尔拥有某种模糊的独立地位。他们迫使阿勒萨尼家族接受一定程度的主权
from the from the al-kalifa dynasty um and from that point on the al-thani family are british clients so they entirely depend on british support to uphold the degree of independence that they that they have so the al-thani is running qatar and the am i right in thinking the al-Farnis are running Qatar. Am I right in thinking the Al-Khalifas are running Bahrain? Is that basically the divide? Yes. So there's a huge – I had never realised the extent to which there's this long history of sort of animosity and rivalry between Bahrain, which is an island, and Qatar, which is a peninsula. Well, yes, but also, I mean, there have been long periods. So under the Al-Khalifa dynasty, initially, they're ruling Qatar.
从阿勒哈利法王朝独立出来，从那时起，阿勒萨尼家族就成为了英国的附庸，因此他们完全依靠英国的支持来维护他们所拥有的独立程度，所以阿勒萨尼家族在统治卡塔尔，我的理解对吗，阿勒法尼斯家族在统治卡塔尔？我的理解对吗，阿勒哈利法家族在统治巴林？基本的分裂就是这样吗？是的。所以这是一个巨大的——我以前从未意识到巴林（一个岛屿）和卡塔尔（一个半岛）之间有着如此悠久的敌意和竞争历史。嗯，是的，不过，我的意思是，也有过很长的时期。所以，在阿勒哈利法王朝统治下，最初他们统治着卡塔尔。
I mean, there is a kind of natural synergy there. And to this day, of course, they're still, you know, they get bundled together very, very naturally. And, you know, these dynasties put down very deep roots. So the Al-Khalifa family still rule Bahrain, and the Al-Fahni family are still very much the big cheeses in Qatar. Right. So Britain is really the midwife of both those dynasties,
我的意思是，那里有一种自然的协同作用。当然，直到今天，他们仍然被非常自然地捆绑在一起。而且，这些王朝扎根很深。因此，阿尔-哈利法家族仍然统治着巴林，而阿尔-塔尼家族仍然是卡塔尔的真正大佬。对的。所以英国真的是这两个王朝的接生婆，
ensuring that they stay in place. Because, of course, throughout the 19th century, as in previous centuries, there are predatory great powers lurking along, you know, beyond the borders. So the Ottomans come back and they retreat again. There's always a threat from the depths of Arabia. The Wahhabis are still very much a presence. And it's not until 1916, so in the middle of the First World War, that Qatar becomes officially a British protectorate. And just before we take a break, Tom,
确保他们留在权力宝座上。因为当然，在整个19世纪，就像前几个世纪一样，掠夺成性的大国潜伏在边境之外。所以奥斯曼帝国卷土重来，然后又撤退了。来自阿拉伯沙漠深处的威胁一直存在。瓦哈比派依然存在。直到1916年，也就是第一次世界大战期间，卡塔尔才正式成为英国的保护国。在我们在休息一下之前，汤姆，
Qatar at this point is, I mean, it's still reliant on what? I mean, pearls, trade, a little bit of trade. Pearls and trade.
此时的卡塔尔，我的意思是，它仍然依赖于什么？我的意思是，珍珠、贸易、一点点贸易。珍珠和贸易。
Yeah. So, so basically there are, there are very few people who live there. I mean, very, very few that it's, there are no major settlements really. And to the degree that there are settlements,
是的，所以基本上那里住的人很少。我的意思是，非常非常少，根本没有真正的主要聚落。就其存在的聚落而言，
they are waystops for ships going up the Gulf and back again. And that is its role. I mean, you know, it has no greater salience than that. And then, of course, everything changes, doesn't it? And we should probably take a break now, Tom, and then come back with this extraordinary transformation in Qatar's fortunes, without which they wouldn't now be hosting the World Cup. They definitely wouldn't. We'll come back to that after the break.
它们是驶往海湾上下船只的中转站。这就是它的角色。我的意思是，你知道，它没有比这更重要的意义了。然后，当然，一切都变了，不是吗？我们现在也许应该休息一下，汤姆，然后带着卡塔尔命运的这种非凡转变回来，没有它，他们现在就不会举办世界杯了。他们绝对不会。我们将在休息后对此进行探讨。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. Welcome back to The Rest is History. We are delving deep into the history of Qatar. We've reached 1916, and Qatar has formally become a British protectorate. So the Qataris have given up their autonomy in foreign affairs,
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《余下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在深入探讨卡塔尔的历史。我们已经来到了1916年，卡塔尔正式成为英国的保护国。所以卡塔尔人放弃了他们的外交自主权，
and they can't make treaties or do anything like that. But the British will let them run their own domestic affairs, won't they? Yeah, I think the British are really reluctant to get involved in anything approximating to domestic affairs. So again, everyone is basically happy. The Qataris can do what they like. The British can ensure that it doesn't fall into the hands, say, of the Ottomans who are enemy competence in 1916 when this relationship is officially established.
他们不能缔结条约或做类似的事情。但英国人会让他们管理自己的国内事务，对吧？是的，我认为英国人非常不愿意卷入任何接近国内事务的事情。所以再次强调，每个人基本上都很高兴。卡塔尔人可以做他们想做的事。英国人可以确保它不会落入1916年建立这种正式关系时作为敌对交战国的奥斯曼帝国手中。
And yeah, everyone's happy, basically. But as we said before the break, Qatar is really, I mean, it's a nothing place. It's kind of Hicksville. But then as you hinted, everything changes because just before the Second World War, they strike oil. And it is discovered that Qatar, this flea-bitten nowhere place, has control of the third highest reserves of natural gas and oil in the world. And this is the Anglo-Persian Oil Company, isn't it, that gets the first concession? And that's basically the ancestor of BP, I think it's fair to say. Yes.
是的，每个人都很高兴，基本上是这样。但正如我们在中场休息前所说的那样，卡塔尔真的——我的意思是，这是一个毫无意义的地方。这是一个乡巴佬聚集地。但正如你所暗示的，一切都变了，因为就在第二次世界大战之前，他们发现了石油。人们发现卡塔尔这个饱受跳蚤肆虐、荒凉无比的地方，拥有世界上第三大天然气和石油储量。这是英波石油公司（Anglo-Persian Oil Company），对吧，它获得了第一个特许权？可以公平地说，这基本上是BP（英国石油公司）的前身。是的。
And so as late as the 1950s, the Qataris remember that decade as the years of hunger because they are not benefiting from this at all. It's still very much Western oil companies that are profiting from it. But that obviously changes. It starts to change in the 60s and definitely changes in the 70s and what happens in the 70s is first of all um in the late 60s as you will know better than me uh the british decide that they can no longer afford to offer protection to these various uh gulf protectorates east of suez so they and that and that actually was a massive so philip larkin
因此，直到20世纪50年代，卡塔尔人还将那个十年铭记为饥饿的岁月，因为他们根本没有从中受益。这仍然主要是西方石油公司在从中获利。但情况显然发生了变化。它在60年代开始改变，并在70年代彻底改变，70年代发生的事情是，首先，在60年代末，正如你比我更清楚的那样，英国人决定他们再也无力向苏伊士运河以东的这些海湾保护国提供保护。所以他们，这实际上是一个巨大的——所以菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin）
wrote a poem about this didn't he did um the statues will still stand the same in squares but we are a country that pulled back our navies because we had no money or something because we had no money exactly uh and and uh i mean we'd actually ended up fighting a sort of rearguard action in aden in the late 1960s and i think it's fair to say the british were very keen to just basically yeah get out of this get out you know as long as they could as long as we could preserve Sweden in the late 1960s. And I think it's fair to say the British were very keen to just basically get out of it. As long as we could preserve our economic interests. I mean, we had no interest in leaving bases and all these kinds of things. Yeah. And this is actually, the Qataris don't welcome this at all. They needed the protection that the Royal Navy had provided.
写过一首关于这个的诗，不是吗？是的，雕像仍会像以前一样立在广场上，但我们是一个撤回海军的国家，因为我们没有钱或者别的什么，因为我们没有钱，完全正确，而且——我的意思是，我们在20世纪60年代末实际上最终在亚丁（Aden）打了一场后卫战，而且我认为可以公平地说，英国人非常渴望基本上——是的，脱离这个泥潭，脱离（只要我们能保持经济利益）。我的意思是，我们对留下基地和其他所有这些事情没有兴趣。是的。事实上，卡塔尔人一点也不欢迎这一点。他们需要皇家海军提供的保护。
And so they're aware that they're going to have to forge an entirely new relationship to the broader world, both the world in general, of which they're now going to be an integral part because they have oil, but also obviously their near neighborhood where there are numerous large powers of which Iran and Saudi Arabia are the two largest and the most predatory. And so Qatar becomes officially independent in 1971. A year later, one of the great themes of Qatari history kicks in, which is rulers of Qatar going on holiday and everything going unstuck. I think one of the lessons of the entire Rest Is History podcast series has been that if you're the ruler of a country, you must never, ever go on holiday because terrible things will follow yes so the the man who does not who has not mastered this lesson
因此他们意识到，他们必须与更广阔的世界建立全新的关系，包括他们现在将成为其中不可分割一部分的世界，因为他们拥有石油，但也包括他们近邻，那里有众多大国，其中伊朗和沙特阿拉伯是最大、最具掠夺性的两个。因此卡塔尔在1971年正式独立。一年后，卡塔尔历史上的一个伟大主题爆发了，那就是卡塔尔统治者去度假，一切都陷入混乱。我认为整个《历史的余烬》播客系列的教训之一就是，如果你是一个国家的统治者，你绝不能、绝对不能去度假，因为可怕的事情会随之发生。是的，所以没有掌握这个教训的人
is Ahmed bin Ali Al Thani who is the ruler of of Qatar and he's always going on holiday he absolutely loves a holiday um and so much so that he actually issues the formal announcement of Qatar's uh independence not in Qatar, but from his villa in Switzerland. That's true patriotic dedication. It really is. It really is. And, you know, I mean, even among the Al-Thani dynasty, who by this point are kind of starting to get into the whole idea of foreign holidays, now that the oil money is flowing in. This is pretty poor behavior. It blocks his copybook. The following year, he goes on holiday again. He goes to Iran for a hunting trip.
是艾哈迈德·本·阿里·阿勒塔尼（Ahmed bin Ali Al Thani），他是卡塔尔的统治者，他总是去度假，他绝对热爱度假——以至于他实际上不是在卡塔尔发布卡塔尔独立的正式宣布，而是在他位于瑞士的别墅里发布的。这是真正的爱国奉献。确实如此。确实如此。而且，你知道，即使在阿勒塔尼家族内部，随着石油资金的涌入，他们此时也开始接受豪华海外度假的概念，这依然是相当糟糕的表现。这给他的履历抹了黑。第二年，他又去度假了。他去伊朗进行了一次狩猎之旅。
While he's on holiday, he's deposed by his cousin, a man called Khalifa bin Hamid. And it's completely a bloodless coup. So Ahmed goes to, I think he goes to Dubai. He ends up dying in London. And Khalifa bin Hamid, he takes over Qatar. And it's under him that you have the OPEC crisis, the oil crisis, so boom times for anyone who has controls, you know, the third largest reserves of oil and gas. And it's all great. And suddenly Doha, from being a sleepy village, kind of occupied by pearl fishers, becomes this increasingly large and significant hub
当他在度假时，他被他的堂弟哈利法·本·哈马德（Khalifa bin Hamid）废黜了。这是一场完全不流血的政变。所以艾哈迈德去了——我想他去了迪拜。他最终死在伦敦。而哈利法·本·哈马德接管了卡塔尔。正是在他统治期间，发生了欧佩克危机、石油危机，所以对于任何控制了（你知道的）世界第三大油气储量的人来说，这是繁荣的时代。这一切都太棒了。突然之间，多哈从一个被珍珠渔民占领的沉睡村庄，变成了日益庞大且重要的枢纽，
where oil ministers from Western countries are constantly jetting in and looking polite. Yes, exactly. Yes, exactly. Meanwhile, of course, if you're the ruler of, say, a few hundred thousand people and you control the third largest oil and gas reserves in the world, that is a bit like kind of walking down a very dark alley with a large quantity of diamonds sticking out of your back pocket. I mean, it's kind of asking for trouble. And so Khalifa bin Hamid's solution to this problem is basically to suck up all he can to Saudi Arabia. So he
西方国家的石油部长们不断乘喷气机飞来飞去，面带礼貌的微笑。是的，绝对的。是的，绝对的。与此同时，当然，如果你统治着几十万人，却控制着世界上第三大油气和天然气储量，这就有点像在一个非常黑暗的小巷里走着，后裤兜里塞着大量的钻石。我的意思是，这简直是自找麻烦。所以哈利法·本·哈马德解决这个问题的办法基本上就是尽可能地巴结沙特阿拉伯。所以他
completely sucks up to the Saudis. I mean, the Saudis are the, you know, they're on his, literally on his doorstep. They're vast, they're incredibly rich. They have even more oil and gas than the Qataris does. And so Qatar's relationship to Saudi Arabia pretty much replicates what previously has been its relationship to Britain. So the Saudis essentially keep out of Qatari internal affairs, and they're happy to do that because Qatar has Sharia law. There's nothing going on there that would be particularly offensive to the Saudis. But the Saudis run their foreign policy.
完全巴结沙特人。我的意思是，沙特人是——你知道的，他们就在他的家门口，字面意义上的家门口。他们庞大无比，极其富有。他们拥有比卡塔尔人更多的石油和天然气。因此卡塔尔与沙特阿拉伯的关系几乎复制了它以前与英国的关系。因此，沙特人基本上不干涉卡塔尔的内部事务，他们也很高兴这样做，因为卡塔尔实行沙特法（Sharia law）。那里没有什么特别会冒犯沙特人的事情。但沙特人掌控着他们的外交政策。
And this lasts throughout the 70s, throughout the 80s, through the first half of the 90s. And then in 1995, Dominic, Khalifa bin Hamid makes a fatal mistake. Don't tell me he goes on holiday, Tom. He goes on holiday and he goes on holiday to Switzerland again. Oh, no. Have they not learned their lesson? A terrible, terrible mistake. And he gets deposed again in a bloodless coup, this time not by his cousin, but by his son, Hamad.
这种情况持续了整个70年代、80年代、90年代前半期。然后在1995年，多米尼克，哈利法·本·哈马德犯了一个致命的错误。别告诉我他又去度假了，汤姆。他去度假了，而且他又去瑞士度假了。哦，不。他们难道还没吸取教训吗？一个可怕、可怕的错误。他又在一场不流血的政变中被废黜了，这次不是被他的堂弟，而是被他的儿子哈马德（Hamad）。
That's very medieval, isn't it? Very. It's very Richard the Lionheart and Henry II. So Hamad is, he's very much a military man. So he went to Sandhurst, I'm proud to say. So the British Military Training College. Yeah. He becomes the army chief of staff
这非常中世纪，不是吗？非常中世纪。这非常像狮心王理查和亨利二世。所以哈马德，他是个不折不扣的军人。所以他去过桑赫斯特（Sandhurst），我很自豪地宣布。也就是英国军事学院。是的。他成为陆军参谋长，
and then he becomes the defence minister. And this is essentially what enables him to stage the coup. So hold on. Am I right in saying, Tom, and I think I've got this right, and this is essentially what enables him to stage the coup so hold on am i right saying tom when i think i've got this right that khalifa bin hamad has been toppled by hamad bin khalifa correct yes crikey well don't get those two mixed up i mean that could be well because bin means son of of course yeah so yes of course yes it is confusing yes so hamad bin khalifa is now the big man and khalifa hamad yeah yeah so khalifa bin hamad yes so he moves to france and then he comes Yes, it is confusing. Yes, it is. So Hamad bin Khalifa is now the big man. So they call him Hamad.
然后他成为了国防部长。这基本上就是他能够发动政变的原因。等等。我没说错吧，汤姆，我想我没记错，这基本上就是他能够发动政变的原因——等等，我是说哈利法·本·哈马德被哈马德·本·哈利法推翻了，对吗？是的。天哪，好吧，别把这两个名字搞混了，因为这可能会——因为“本”（bin）的意思就是……的儿子，当然是的。所以，是的，当然，这确实很令人困惑。所以哈马德·本·哈利法现在是大人物了，而哈利法·本·哈马德……是的，所以哈利法·本·哈马德，是的。所以他搬到了法国，然后我想他在2004年左右回到了卡塔尔，然后可能在大约十年后去世。所以基本上，我的意思是，这是一个——一方面，正如你所说，这一切都相当中世纪，但另一方面，我的意思是，你知道，退休去法国并没有什么不好的。是的。大概带着巨额资金吧。是的，巨额资金。
Yeah. Yeah, so Khalifa bin Hamad, yes. So he moves to France and then he comes back to Qatar, I think, in 2004 or something like that, and then he dies maybe a decade later. So basically, I mean, this is, yeah, on one level, as you say, it's all quite medieval, but on another, it's, I mean, you know, there are worse things
是的。是的，哈利法·本·哈马德，是的。所以他搬到了法国，然后我想他在2004年左右回到了卡塔尔，然后大约十年后他去世了。所以基本上，我的意思是，一方面，正如你所说，这都挺中世纪的，但另一方面，我的意思是，你知道，还有比这更糟糕的事情
than retiring to France. Yes. Presumably with an enormous amount of money. Yeah, enormous amount. Yes. other it's i mean you know there are worse things than retiring to finance and yeah i mean it's presumably with an enormous amount of money i mean yeah enormous amount yes so yeah i think i think you know it's it's there are worse things that could happen anyway so hamad is a very very um ambitious man and he has very very big plans for q. And these plans do not involve being a Saudi licks battle. He wants to make Qatar essentially into such a geopolitical big beast that the Saudis won't be able to keep Qatar under their thumb. And obviously, this is a very, very startling ambition, considering how small Qatar is, how vulnerable it is, and how large Saudi Arabia is. And so the spectacle of Hamid setting out to establish a completely independent foreign policy
是的。另一方面，我的意思是，你知道，退休去法国并没有什么不好的，而且，是的，大概带着巨额资金吧。我的意思是，是的，巨额资金。所以，是的，我想——我认为，你知道，这——还有比这更糟糕的事情可能会发生。不管怎样，哈马德是一个非常非常有野心的人，他对卡塔尔有着非常非常宏伟的计划。这些计划并不包括成为沙特的小跟班。他想把卡塔尔基本上变成一个地缘政治上的庞然大物，让沙特人无法再将卡塔尔压制在他们的手掌心。显然，考虑到卡塔尔是如此之小、如此脆弱，而沙特阿拉伯又是如此庞大，这是一个非常非常惊人的野心。因此，哈马德着手建立完全独立的外交政策的这一壮举，
is very, very alarming to the Saudis, and also actually quite alarming to its other neighbours as well. And so it's a very, very bold policy. And it's essentially astonishing that he's pulled it off. And the fact that the World Cup is going on in Qatar is in a way the kind of the cherry on the cake of his success. So it's an astonishing, astonishing feat. I mean, I think one of the great feats of recent geopolitics. So Tom, Al Jazeera, the media network is part of that story, isn't it?
让沙特人感到非常非常震惊，实际上也让它的其他邻国感到相当震惊。所以这是一个非常非常大胆的政策。他竟然能成功，这简直令人震惊。世界杯能在卡塔尔举行，在某种程度上可以说是他成功的锦上添花。这是一个令人惊叹、令人惊叹的壮举。我的意思是，我认为这是近代地缘政治的伟大壮举之一。所以，汤姆，半岛电视台（Al Jazeera）这个媒体网络就是那个故事的一部分，对吧？
It is. This is part of his project. So the question is, how does he do this? How does he make this fabulously rich? I mean, the wealth is the given. But even so, if you only have kind of 300,000 people and no real army, and you're next to Saudi Arabia, and you want to strike out on a novel course, how do you do this? How do you exploit your wealth? So there are a number of ways in which he does it. Basically, he sets out to make Qatar the kind of the center of gravity for the whole of the Arab world. That's his aim.
是的。这是他的项目的一部分。所以问题是，他是怎么做到的？他是如何做到这一点的？——这异常富有。我的意思是，财富是既定的。但即便如此，如果你只有大约30万人，没有真正的军队，又紧邻沙特阿拉伯，而你还想开辟一条新颖的道路，你是怎么做到的？你是如何利用你的财富的？所以他有很多方法可以做到这一点。基本上，他着手让卡塔尔成为整个阿拉伯世界的重心。这就是他的目标。
And he does it in all kinds of ways. So he sets education as an obvious one. So he sets up this kind of incredible complex called Education City. All the water jets are keeping the manicured lawns absolutely green and exquisite. He invites Americans, British, French to set up a kind of sub-departments of their own universities there. So it becomes a great educational hub. He establishes Doha as a transport hub. So, you know, planes from across the world. It becomes, I think, one of the largest transport hubs in the entire world. And then, as you say, he possibly the most kind of decisive step that he takes.
他是通过各种方式做到的。所以他把教育作为一个显而易见的目标。因此，他建立了这个令人难以置信的综合体，叫做“教育城”（Education City）。所有的喷水灭火器都让那些修剪整齐的草坪保持着绝对的翠绿和精致。他邀请美国人、英国人、法国人在那里建立他们自己大学的分支机构。因此它成为了一个伟大的教育枢纽。他把多哈打造成了一个交通枢纽。所以，来自世界各地的飞机。它成为了——我认为——整个世界最大的交通枢纽之一。然后，正如你所说，他采取了可能是最果断的一步。
And one that really shows a kind of understanding of how the world is going to work kind of ahead of a lot of people is that he sets up this new service called Al Jazeera, which is initially Arab language, then English and then various other languages designed to be a kind of an Arab CNN, so an international news service. And he does this, it's pre-internet. And so the effect of this essentially is that it enables Qatar to seize control of the news agenda across the Middle East, wherever Arabic is spoken as the main language. It is Al Jazeera that is setting the agenda. That is a huge, huge source of power. I think the assumption is that by raising the profile of Qatar, by establishing Al Jazeera as the equivalent of CNN or the BBC, it will give it a global brand that in turn will ensure that Qatar can't just be snuffed out. Right.
这一步真正展现了超越许多人的、对世界将如何运作的深刻理解，那就是他建立了一个名为“半岛电视台”的新服务，最初是阿拉伯语的，然后是英语的，接着是其他各种语言，旨在成为一种阿拉伯版的CNN，也就是一个国际新闻服务机构。他这样做时，互联网甚至还没普及。因此，这从根本上产生的效果是，它使卡塔尔能够夺取整个中东地区新闻议程的控制权，无论哪里将阿拉伯语作为主要语言。正是半岛电视台在设定议程。这是一个巨大、巨大的权力来源。我认为人们的设想是，通过提升卡塔尔的知名度，通过将半岛电视台打造成CNN或BBC的同等地位，它将赋予卡塔尔一个全球品牌，从而反过来确保卡塔尔不会轻易被消灭。对的。
Because it will have a kind of global resonance. Yes. People will have heard of it. Everybody will know about it. And you can't just suddenly send in your troops and crush it because it'll be a big story, which it wouldn't be if no one had heard of Qatar. Exactly. So the question is, does this work?
因为这会产生一种全球共鸣。是的。人们会听说它。每个人都会知道这件事。你不能突然派军队去粉碎它，因为这将是一个大新闻，如果没人听说过卡塔尔，那就不会是这样了。完全正确。所以问题是，这管用吗？
There are definitely downsides to it because I think that Hamad's assumption was that making Qatar a center of world attention would only be good. But obviously, it isn't only good, because the more that attention is paid to Qatar, the more people are aware of problems with it that the Qatari government might want to sweep under the carpet. So it's got the World Cup. It's the center of world attention. Here we are doing an episode about it. Qatar is all over the, you know, I mean, people will be watching the football from Qatar across the globe. But the process by which Qatar got the World Cup and the way in which its stadia were built has brought a lot of very very negative publicity so it's focused attention on
这绝对有负面影响，因为我认为哈马德的设想是，让卡塔尔成为世界关注的中心只会是好事。但显然，这并非只有好处，因为人们对卡塔尔的关注越多，就越会意识到卡塔尔政府可能想要掩盖的问题。所以它举办了世界杯。它是世界关注的中心。我们现在正在制作一集关于它的节目。卡塔尔到处都是，你知道的，我的意思是，全世界的人们都在观看来自卡塔尔的足球比赛。但是卡塔尔获得世界杯的过程以及其体育场的建造方式带来了很多非常非常负面的宣传，所以它把人们的注意力集中在
on corruption on boat rigging on bribery and perhaps particularly on the kind of the human rights offenses so uh qatar you know has this very small native population it's entirely dependent for uh large infrastructure projects on migrant labor and there have been all kinds of stories reports saying that basically this is a kind of modern form of slavery. Right, Indians, Nepalese, and so on. Yeah, that they're brought over, they have their passports taken away, and essentially if they complain, they have no recourse at all. So they're sort of working in horrendous conditions.
腐败、操纵竞标、行贿，或许特别是人权侵害上。所以，你知道的，卡塔尔有着非常少量的本地人口，它完全依赖移民劳工来进行大型基础设施项目，并且有各种各样的故事和报道称，这基本上是一种现代形式的奴隶制。没错，印度人、尼泊尔人等等。是的，他们被带到这里，护照被没收，基本上如果他们抱怨，他们根本没有任何申诉途径。所以他们是在极其恶劣的条件 下工作。
And, you know, if some stories are to be believed, quite a high death toll. Absolutely. And so that hasn't redounded entirely to its credit. The other problem that it has is that on the Al Jazeera theme, is that, again, it doesn't entirely redound. It's not entirely a positive. Because if you're controlling the news agenda,
而且，你知道，如果某些报道可信的话，死亡人数相当高。绝对是这样。因此，这并没有完全为它增光。它面临的另一个问题是，关于半岛电视台的主题，同样，这并没有完全带来好局。这并不完全是正面的。因为如果你在控制新闻议程，
then again, that makes you an object of criticism. So CNN is criticized, Fox News is criticized, the BBC is criticized, precisely because they have the reach that they do, because they have the kind of reputation that they do. Therefore, if people feel that they're not accommodating themselves to their own political perspectives, then they come to hate them. And much the same thing happens with Al Jazeera, and particularly because Qatar deliberately sets out to be friends essentially with everyone. So the classic example of this is that it invites Hamas to come and talk, but at the same time, it's playing host to Israeli trade delegations. And it doesn't go down well with radical Muslim
那么同样，这会让你成为批评的对象。因此，CNN受到批评，福克斯新闻受到批评，BBC受到批评，恰恰是因为它们具有那样的影响力，因为它们拥有那种声誉。因此，如果人们觉得它们没有迎合他们自己的政治观点，那么他们就会开始痛恨它们。半岛电视台也发生了几乎同样的事情，特别是因为卡塔尔刻意打算基本上与所有人交朋友。这方面的经典例子是，它邀请哈马斯前来对话，但与此同时，它又在接待以色列贸易代表团。这在激进的穆斯林
opinion. And Tom, what about the Arab Spring? So the Arab Spring starts in what, 2010 or so? Yes, exactly. So prior to the Arab Spring, among those Arab states that regard any contact with Israel, the fact that it's prepared to sup even with a long spoon with trade delegations, it's not entirely a positive from the Arab point of view. And it's seen as too accommodating to Israel. But then with the Arab Spring, you get criticism from the other side, which is that it's an ally of Islamic terrorism, of Muslim terrorism. Because what happens in the Arab Spring is that Al Jazeera is not just a kind of objective reporter. It's absolutely a player.
舆论中并不受欢迎。那么汤姆，“阿拉伯之春”呢？所以“阿拉伯之春”始于什么，2010年左右？是的，完全正确。所以在阿拉伯之春之前，在那些认为与以色列有任何接触的阿拉伯国家中，它甚至愿意用一把长勺与贸易代表团共进晚餐，从阿拉伯的角度来看，这并不完全是件好事。它被视为对以色列过于迁就。但随着阿拉伯之春的到来，你遭到了来自另一边的批评，即它是伊斯兰恐怖主义、穆斯林恐怖主义的盟友。因为在阿拉伯之春发生的事情是，半岛电视台不仅仅是一个客观的报道者。它绝对是一个参与者。
Spreading news, spreading information, all that stuff. Exactly. And particularly what the Qataris do, and therefore Al Jazeera, which is under the Qatari thumb, is that they back the Muslim Brotherhood. And the Muslim Brotherhood are, well, they're condemned. So it's all very complicated. I mean, they're quite a kind of venerable organization. Their origins lie in Egypt. And so the Muslim Brotherhood come to power in Tunisia and they come to power in Egypt and more specifically in Egypt. And I say specifically because Egypt is, you know, it's one of the kind of the great political and cultural centers of the Arab world, much more than Tunisia and um there's a lot of nervousness from the saudis from the americans um from basically from any from anyone in the arab world who has suspicions of the muslim brotherhood and
传播新闻，传播信息，诸如此类。完全正确。特别是卡塔尔人所做的，因此处于卡塔尔控制之下的半岛电视台，他们支持穆斯林兄弟会。而穆斯林兄弟会，嗯，他们受到了谴责。所以这一切非常复杂。我的意思是，他们是一个相当古老的组织。他们的起源在埃及。因此，穆斯林兄弟会在突尼斯和埃及掌权，更具体地说是在埃及。我之所以说具体，是因为埃及是，你知道的，它是阿拉伯世界的伟大政治和文化中心之一，远比突尼斯重要，而且沙特人、美国人以及阿拉伯世界中任何对穆斯林兄弟会有疑虑的人都感到非常紧张，
basically that's everyone in power um so the muslim brotherhood come to power in egypt under the uh under the rule of a guy called morsi and and he very rapidly gets toppled. And the Saudis accuse the Qataris of backing terrorism. And you may feel that that is a pot calling a kettle black, and you'd be right to do so. But hypocrisy is very much a feature of politics in the Middle East. And it doesn't stop. Soudi united arab emirates bahrain qatar's near neighbor and in due course egypt from first of all recalling their ambassadors to qatar and then severing all ties with qatar and closing all transport links with qatar they try to blockade qatar yeah so they they they blockade it this is 2017 or so? Yes. Trump piles in.
基本上掌权者都是如此。所以穆斯林兄弟会在一个叫穆尔西的人的统治下在埃及掌权，而他很快就被推翻了。沙特人指责卡塔尔人支持恐怖主义。你可能会觉得这是五十步笑百步，你的想法是对的。但虚伪很大程度上是中东政治的一个特征。这并没有阻止沙特、阿拉伯联合酋长国、巴林（卡塔尔的近邻）以及后来的埃及，首先召回他们驻卡塔尔的大使，然后断绝与卡塔尔的一切关系，并关闭与卡塔尔的所有交通连接，他们试图封锁卡塔尔。是的，他们封锁了它。这是2017年左右吗？是的。特朗普插手了。
He's very much on the side of the Saudis, inevitably. And a resolution isn't brokered until 2021. Crikey, only last year. Yeah. And that is under the aegis of the US and Kuwait. And Trump very much claims the credit for it. But of course. Of course.
不可避免地，他非常站在沙特一边。直到2021年才通过协商达成决议。天哪，就在去年。是的。那是在美国和科威特的庇护下进行的。特朗普极力邀功。但当然。当然。
So he says it was all him. So, you know, obviously there are kind of dangers for Qatar in this path. I mean, it hasn't been, you know, entirely without – and also the fact that it has very good relations with Iran as well. I was about to say, there's a colossal superpower – superpower is the wrong word. Kind of regional power. Yeah, regional great power rivalry, isn't there, between Saudi Arabia and Iran.
所以他说这一切都是他的功劳。所以，你知道，显然卡塔尔在这条道路上有危险。我的意思是，这并不是完全没有——而且它与伊朗也有非常好的关系。我正要说，有一个庞大的超级大国——超级大国这个词用错了。某种区域大国。是的，沙特阿拉伯和伊朗之间存在着区域大国竞争，对吧？
And Qatar is trying to play them off and find its role within that. But it may well be that it's bust up with the Saudis actually boosted its relations with Iran. And the counter view to this is that actually there are know, there are upsides to it as well, that it hasn't all been down, because otherwise they wouldn't be adopting this policy and it wouldn't have been so successful. So Qatar does have a kind of channel of communication to Iran, for instance. So that is something that can be activated if needs be. And it has definitely played a pretty positive role in certain regional conflicts. So in Lebanon, for instance, it's been an honest broker. And you see banners in Lebanon saying, thank you, Qatar. sense, with Al Jazeera, the Qataris have slightly been riding a tiger. It's definitely raised their profile.
卡塔尔正试图在他们之间搞平衡，并在其中找到自己的角色。但很可能它与沙特的决裂实际上提升了它与伊朗的关系。与此相反的观点是，实际上，这也有积极的一面，并不全是坏事，否则他们就不会采取这种政策，也不会取得如此成功。所以卡塔尔确实拥有通往伊朗的沟通渠道。因此，如果需要的话，可以启动这一渠道。它在某些地区冲突中绝对发挥了相当积极的作用。例如在黎巴嫩，它一直是一个诚实的中间人。你在黎巴嫩可以看到这样的横幅：“谢谢你，卡塔尔。”从某种意义上说，通过半岛电视台，卡塔尔人有点像骑虎难下。这绝对提高了他们的知名度。
It's definitely given them power, but that power is quite a treacherous thing. And on its own, I think it would be insufficient to secure their independence. And this was something that was very, very much brought home to the Qataris. And in fact, it may well have played a crucial role in the deposition of Hamad's father, which was the invasion of Kuwait by Saddam Hussein, because it really brought home to everyone along the line of the Gulf that they needed military protection and they needed more solid bulwark than um than even al jazeera could provide and so basically they have they've adopted two policies to ensure that they have great power protection the first of those is economic so they have this vast sovereign wealth fund and they've invested they they own the shard for instance in in london london's tallest building. They own Paris Saint-Germain. So that's another football investment.
这绝对赋予了他们权力，但这种权力是一件相当危险的事情。单凭这一点，我认为还不足以确保他们的独立性。这一点深深地印在了卡塔尔人的脑海中。事实上，这很可能在哈马斯父亲被废黜的过程中起到了至关重要的作用，那就是萨达姆·侯赛因对科威特的入侵，因为它确实让海湾沿岸的每个人都清楚地认识到，他们需要军事保护，他们需要比甚至半岛电视台所能提供的更坚固的堡垒。因此，基本上，他们采取了两种政策来确保他们获得大国保护。第一种是经济政策，所以他们拥有这笔庞大的主权财富基金，他们进行了投资，例如他们拥有伦敦的地标建筑“碎片大厦”，伦敦最高的建筑。他们拥有巴黎圣日耳曼。所以这是另一笔足球投资。
The ultimate plastic football team, Tom. Various German car companies. So they've invested in iconic properties investments within individual Western countries that helps to raise their profile. But also, of course, what they have done with their reserves of liquefied natural gas is that they have supplied it to the UK. The UK has been drawing on natural gas from Qatar, relying on its long-term relationship with Qatar. And that's something that obviously is- Yeah, very timely. But they've also been supplying liquefied natural gas to China, to Japan, to all kinds of countries that will therefore have a stake in upholding its independence.
终极的塑料足球队，汤姆。还有各种德国汽车公司。因此，他们投资了标志性资产，在西方国家内部进行投资，这有助于提高他们的知名度。当然，他们利用液化天然气储量所做的是，他们将其供应给英国。英国一直在利用来自卡塔尔的天然气，依赖其与卡塔尔的长期关系。这显然是——是的，非常及时。但他们也一直在向中国、日本以及各种各样的国家供应液化天然气，因此这些国家将在维护其独立性方面拥有切身利益。
And the other thing that they have done is from 1996 onwards, they started building a huge airbase at a place called Alia dade a vast vast air base and it was very much a kind of come hither you know wiggling of the bottom towards the united states uh because they knew the united states you know its air force needs it it needs a base um it had previously been in saudi arabia obviously relations between the United States and Saudi Arabia because of 9-11 and in due course and everything. Very, very rocky. And so the U.S. moves its air base to Al Udeid. And it's actually, it's the largest overseas, U.S. overseas air base anywhere in the world. So you would think that would be the ultimate protection, I suppose, wouldn't you?
他们做的另一件事是，从1996年开始，他们开始在一个叫乌代德的地方建造一个巨大的空军基地，一个非常非常巨大的空军基地，这在很大程度上是一种“快来吧”（你知道的，向美国扭动屁股）的姿态，因为他们知道美国，你知道的，它的空军需要它，它需要一个基地。它以前显然在沙特阿拉伯，由于“9·11”事件及后来的种种原因，美国和沙特阿拉伯之间的关系变得非常非常紧张。因此，美国将空军基地迁至乌代德。事实上，它是世界上最大的美国海外空军基地。所以你可能会认为这是终极保护，对吧？
Well, it's a base and the the raf station there as well other other western air force the the us have 10 000 troops there uh it's it's a regional command so that is really the kind of yeah the underpinning of uh qatari independence they had they they have they're indispensable to the global economy and absolutely at the moment i mean you know it's kind of such an odd coincidence that the world cup should be going on at the same time as its supplies of liquefied natural gas to the world is they're essentially keeping the global economy ticking so as i say i think that qatar is think that Qatar is a really astonishing state. It's played all the various elements of late 20th and early 21st century politics very, very cleverly.
嗯，这是一个基地，那里的英国皇家空军基地也是如此，其他西方空军也是如此。美国在那里驻扎了1万人，这是一个区域司令部，所以这确实是卡塔尔独立的基石。他们对全球经济不可或缺，目前绝对如此。你知道，世界杯竟然与它向全球供应液化天然气的时期同时进行，这真是太奇怪的巧合了，它们基本上在维持全球经济的运转。所以正如我所说，我认为卡塔尔是一个真正令人惊叹的国家。它非常非常聪明地利用了20世纪末和21世纪初政治的各种要素。
And unless it had done so, it simply wouldn't be in the position that it is today of hosting the World Cup. Tom, you wonder whether the World Cup will be a blessing or a curse for Qatar. Because, of course, as you said earlier, the World Cup has brought a level of scrutiny that it's never had before. So there's two ways of looking at that. One is to say, well, let's look back to when Russia had the World Cup in 2018. Actually, you know, Vladimir Putin was able
如果它没有这样做，它根本不会处于今天举办世界杯的位置。汤姆，你想知道世界杯对卡塔尔来说是福还是祸。因为，正如你刚才所说，世界杯带来了前所未有的审查水平。所以有两种看待方式。一种是回顾2018年俄罗斯举办世界杯的时候。事实上，你知道，弗拉基米尔·普京能够
to kind of get away scot-free. Everybody actually turned up and said, oh, Russia's lovely, you know, and nobody talked about human rights or any of these kinds of things. And any sort of criticism was kind of drowned out by excitement at the organization of the tournament and the spectacle and all that stuff. On the other hand, there has already been quite sort of bad publicity
逃脱惩罚。每个人都来了，说，哦，俄罗斯太可爱了，你知道，没有人谈论人权或任何此类事情。对赛事的兴奋、奇观以及所有这些东西的激动，把任何形式的批评都淹没了。另一方面，已经有相当糟糕的宣传了
for Qatar with the deaths of migrant workers, with the environmental costs of playing the tournament in somewhere that's so hot. Well, and also I think, I mean, don't you think, I mean, among football fans who will obviously be the people who will be paying closest attention to it, a feeling that this is a country without any football culture really. Yeah.
对于卡塔尔来说，伴随着移民工人的死亡，在如此炎热的地方举办比赛的环境成本。嗯，而且我也认为，难道你不认为，在那些显然会最密切关注它的球迷中，有一种感觉，认为这是一个真正没有任何足球文化的国家。是的。
And it's in the middle of the European season. Yes, I mean, it feels... Lots of people are mildly resentful of it. I mean, that's not crucial. There's a sort of sense, isn't there? But I think... It's a sporting tournament. I mean, that's not crucial. There's a sort of sense, isn't there? But I think it's a sporting tournament. I mean... That's been bought.
而且它在欧洲赛季的中间。是的，我的意思是，感觉……很多人对此感到轻微的怨恨。我的意思是，这并不是关键。有一种感觉，不是吗？但我认为……这是一场体育赛事。我的意思是，这并不是关键。有一种感觉，不是吗？但我认为这是一场体育赛事。我的意思是……那是买来的。
That's been bought. And unlike... It's a rich man's toy. Of course, all sporting tournaments are like that. And the World Cup has always had, you know, its political dark side in Argentina in 1978, for example. Well, we discussed that in our episodes. Yeah, absolutely.
那是买来的。并且不像……这是有钱人的玩具。当然，所有的体育赛事都是这样的。世界杯一直都有其政治黑暗面，例如1978年的阿根廷。嗯，我们在之前的节目中讨论过这一点。是的，绝对如此。
But this does feel like... Well, it'll be interesting to see how it plays out. You know, if the tournament... I sort of think if the tournament passes off triumphantly and everybody says it was brilliantly organized and they had a whale of a time and it was a fantastic sporting spectacle, then the truth, unwelcome as it may be, will probably be a lot of the criticism just dies down. Don't you think? I mean, that's what happened in Russia in 2018. I mean, I think, I mean, ultimately, Qatar's security doesn't depend on Western public opinion. It doesn't really matter. It's definitely useful.
但这确实感觉像……嗯，看看事态如何发展会很有趣。你知道，如果比赛圆满结束，每个人都说组织得好极了，他们玩得很开心，这是一场棒极了的体育盛宴，那么真相——尽管可能不受欢迎——很可能会让许多批评声自行消退。你不觉得吗？我的意思是，2018年的俄罗斯就是这样的。我的意思是，我认为，归根结底，卡塔尔的安全并不取决于西方公众舆论。这其实没关系。这绝对是有用的。
I mean, it helps. It helps that, you know, people in the West associate it with prosperity, with wealth, with progress, with bling, with nice things, with, you know with fancy island developments, all that kind of stuff. I mean, it does help. And therefore, a successful World Cup will obviously do a huge amount to raise its profile. But ultimately, the basis of Qatar's security remains that American air base and the need that the world has particularly over this winter for the um for the gas that it can supply i think that's all true that's all true but that
我的意思是，这有帮助。这有帮助，你知道，西方的人们将它与繁荣、财富、进步、浮华、美好的事物、花哨的岛屿开发项目等联系起来。我的意思是，这确实有帮助。因此，一届成功的世界杯显然会在很大程度上提升它的知名度。但归根结底，卡塔尔安全的基石仍然是那个美国空军基地，以及世界特别是今年冬天对其能够供应的天然气的需求。我认为这都是真的，都是真的，但
all of that said i think a few future historians will undoubtedly mention this the fact that because it's the most extraordinary symbol isn't it of the sort of changing balance of economic and political power in the world, that the World Cup is now being held in a country like Qatar, which would have been inconceivable even 40 or 50 years ago. And you could... Well, I mean, I think, yeah, I think it serves as a kind of unsettling emblem of the modern economy, where you do have this tiny minority of qataris you have
话虽如此，未来的历史学家无疑会提到这一点，因为它是世界经济和政治力量平衡变化的非凡象征，世界杯现在竟然在一个像卡塔尔这样的国家举行，这在四五十年前是不可想象的。你可以……嗯，我的意思是，我认为，是的，我认为它成为了现代经济的一种令人不安的象征，在那里你确实有这极少数的卡塔尔人，你有
you know subsection of western expats and then you have a kind of vast heritage uh kind of almost slaves laboring beneath them which i get you know you could say is uh you know that's the way the global economy is organized now and all you know and and and with the um the current energy crisis you know the sense that the whole thing is so fundamental to the functioning of the global economy you know it's not just a kind of you know a peripheral side show i mean this is really central to to keeping our lights on over the winter you know all kinds of things so there's a lot to reflect on but before we end tom um and and by the way that was um as you would say that was an absolute tour de force i can't thank you enough but tom we should say a little bit about the next uh few weeks for us
你知道的，西方外派人员的子集，然后你有一种庞大的传统——某种几乎像奴隶一样的劳动力在他们脚下劳作，这我明白，你知道，你可以说，这就是现在全球经济组织的方式，而且你知道，伴随着当前的能源危机，这种整体感觉对于全球经济的运作是如此基础，你知道，它不仅仅是一种边缘的侧面秀，我的意思是，这对于我们在冬天保持灯火通明真的很核心，你知道，各种各样的事情，所以有很多值得反思的地方。但在我们结束之前，汤姆，顺便说一句，正如你会说的那样，那绝对是一次精彩的演说，我对你感激不尽。但汤姆，我们应该简单谈谈我们接下来的几周
because not only will you and I be watching the football, but also we will be releasing podcasts every day so that we get through the 32 – well, the 31 left, because we've done Qatar. There are 31 more countries to go. And with those 31 countries, we won't be focusing – we won't be doing potted histories. We'll be focusing on individual aspects.
因为不仅你和我将观看足球比赛，而且我们还将每天发布播客，这样我们就能讲完32个——嗯，还剩31个，因为我们已经讲了卡塔尔。还有31个国家要讲。对于这31个国家，我们不会专注于——我们不会做简明历史。我们将专注于各个方面。
So do you want to give us a couple of highlights of your highlights of the weeks ahead? I think what's been wonderful about doing these is that we've been able to fix on aspects of various aspects of history, and perhaps particularly regions of the world that we otherwise perhaps wouldn't have looked at, and come up with some really extraordinary episodes, events, characters. And I've certainly learned a huge amount. So what have I learned? I've learned more than I ever knew about Russia's most famous Cameroonian 18th century general. From a huge pool there, Tom. Obviously, there are lots of them, uh astonishing story um and i've learned that
所以你想给我们透露未来几周的几个精彩看点吗？我认为做这些节目的美妙之处在于，我们能够专注于历史的各个方面，或许特别是我们平时可能不会关注的世界各个地区，并想出一些真正非凡的剧集、事件、人物。我当然学到了很多东西。那么我学到了什么？我学到了比以往更多的关于俄罗斯最著名的18世纪喀麦隆将军的知识。从庞大的资料库里，汤姆。显然有很多，这是一个令人惊叹的故事，我了解到
costa rica i literally knew nothing about the history of costa rica i've learned that um a really remote a really remarkable story which i thoroughly commend to listeners who who may think costa rican history i'm not interested in that you will be listen to it and yourself i enjoyed listening to you talking about dido the great carthaginian queen um on whether or not she did exist uh so that's for two yes i like this i enjoyed hearing you were very good on the ashanti wars in the history of ghana uh and but my favorite and that if there's one podcast i think people should listen to is the podcast about australia um and the story of summerton man which is I mean basically the best murder mystery story I think I've ever heard so people have got that to look forward to yeah so lots to come and I just
哥斯达黎加，我以前对哥斯达黎加的历史一无所知，我了解到，这是一个真正偏远、真正非凡的故事，我向那些可能认为“哥斯达黎加历史我对这个不感兴趣”的听众强烈推荐，你会感兴趣的，去听听吧。我很享受听你谈论迦太基伟大女王狄多，关于她是否真的存在——所以这是第二点。是的，我很喜欢这个，你关于加纳历史上的阿香提战争讲得非常好。但我的最爱——如果有一期播客我认为人们应该听的话——就是关于澳大利亚的播客，以及萨默顿男人的故事，我的听后感是，这基本上是我听过的最好的谋杀悬疑故事，所以大家可以期待一下。是的，所以有很多内容要推出，我只是
hope that you don't get bored of our voices Tom I don't believe anyone no one could possibly get bored I think so enjoy the World Cup enjoy the Rest is History's World Cup extravaganza. And we will see you soon. Goodbye. Very soon. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to the Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
希望你们不会厌倦我们的声音，汤姆。我不相信任何人，没有人会感到厌倦。我认为是这样的。享受世界杯，享受“历史其余部分”的世界剧场盛宴。我们很快就会再见。再见。非常快。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚
launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先收听本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。